Caption: never assorted I'm gonna start perfect
Caption: good evening I'm sorry for the technical
Caption: interruptions well first of all thank
Caption: you very much for Yahoo and DDD purse
Caption: and especially also for bankwest for
Caption: hosting this and inviting me over to
Caption: Perth it's in fact the first time I've
Caption: been in purse so great to see you all so
Caption: now about this function probably
Caption: programming thing well it's let's take a
Caption: step back let's not start with frontal
Caption: programming let's start with more slowly
Caption: so in the 60s when Edsger Dijkstra
Caption: introduced structured programming there
Caption: were a lot of developers who call it his
Caption: his his the ideas he put forward
Caption: academic and not very convincing but
Caption: today if we when we teach programming I
Caption: mean nobody would even entertain the
Caption: idea of doing something different a
Caption: little later when people like L&K
Caption: introduced object-oriented programming
Caption: and languages like small talk in C++
Caption: again people said well that's kind of
Caption: cute but hey I can write my stuff in C
Caption: and it's just okay so now we are again
Caption: in such a paradigm shift in our industry
Caption: and it's all the same things all over
Caption: again isn't functional programming to
Caption: academic or impractical well maybe it's
Caption: okay for those ninja rock star
Caption: programmer people but not for the
Caption: average developer
Caption: and also it's inefficient and definitely
Caption: way to complicate it so looks like we
Caption: are going through these phases right
Caption: interestingly it's not just us it turns
Caption: out that a smart person a professor for
Caption: Communication Studies Rota Everett
Caption: Rogers he's written a book actually
Caption: called a diffusion of innovation and
Caption: this is a theory which has been
Caption: corroborated by business scientists over
Caption: and over again whether it's railroads
Caption: these waters smartphones any kind of
Caption: technological invention they all
Caption: propagate through a social group in more
Caption: or less the same manner so if you look
Caption: at these curves the blue curve is the
Caption: number of new people adopting a
Caption: technology and the yellow curve is the
Caption: sum of all people who've adopted this
Caption: technology so now when we look at
Caption: functional programming or any
Caption: development develop a technology then
Caption: question is of course what does it mean
Caption: for somebody have been adopted like it's
Caption: a hard core do you have to be a hard
Caption: core Haskell programmer or isn't it if
Caption: you use react in JavaScript I mean
Caption: you're doing functional programming so
Caption: from that count so we may wonder where
Caption: are we here on this scale so I would say
Caption: we are kind of in the transition phase
Caption: between early adopters early majority
Caption: and that's important because these
Caption: different groups of people
Caption: they adopt technology and innovation for
Caption: different reasons and in a different
Caption: manner so if you are interested in kind
Caption: of promoting something then it's very
Caption: important that you understand where you
Caption: are and you understand what the mindset
Caption: of the people you are talking to is so
Caption: let's look at these groups one by one so
Caption: the innovators in the when we are
Caption: talking about programming languages
Caption: these are people like programming
Caption: language resources the people who would
Caption: design and standardize the programming
Caption: language the people who write the
Caption: compilers the ecosystems the base
Caption: libraries the initial tools these are
Caption: very very people who are very happy to
Caption: take risk right they define a new
Caption: programming language go to the extent of
Caption: writing an entire compiler just to prove
Caption: to the world that it's better a base for
Caption: some measure of betterness right so
Caption: that's high risk they're also usually in
Caption: the case of pl these people typically
Caption: have a background in programming
Caption: language theory they know compilers may
Caption: be quite a lot of math background so
Caption: it's a particular type of person all
Caption: right and then when you go to the early
Caption: adopters the early adopters usually have
Caption: good connection to the innovators and
Caption: yet those are the people on your team on
Caption: your test team who who take something
Caption: new programming language and do the
Caption: hobby project and the weekends kind of
Caption: upskill themselves until one day they go
Caption: in the meeting I think you should use
Caption: this new technology these are people who
Caption: bring something new into an existing
Caption: group right they are not like the
Caption: innovators they didn't make it up
Caption: themselves but they also typically they
Caption: have good connection to innovators
Caption: they're happy to read a research paper
Caption: with lots of math in it spend a long
Caption: time to understand it in order to then
Caption: be able to be the first person in their
Caption: peer group to say I understand this I
Caption: can
Caption: show you how we can do everything better
Caption: all right still prepare to take quite a
Caption: lot of risk a lot of investment before
Caption: there's a payoff right but they don't
Caption: want to start from scratch they wouldn't
Caption: want to write a new compilers they want
Caption: a compiler tools should be kind of okay
Caption: but they're happy to figure it out and
Caption: then then the early majority that's the
Caption: rest of the team they're going like we
Caption: have to solve a problem right is this
Caption: stuff ready for production can we use
Caption: this right so that's a totally different
Caption: mindset and they don't want to sit read
Caption: a research paper read up about some math
Caption: behind it they just want to use it if
Caption: it's not ready to be used if it's not
Caption: ready to solve a problem then rather
Caption: let's wait a little longer
Caption: and the people have solved this problem
Caption: okay so how do we get the early majority
Caption: into a functional program so now I mean
Caption: I can kind of guess the answer already
Caption: from earlier questions being asked but
Caption: who would say well I I'm doing frontal
Caption: programming okay a few people that's not
Caption: too surprising because it kind of was
Caption: probably going to be the inverse of
Caption: people what do you do functional
Caption: programming introductory course okay so
Caption: I'm talking about you people all right
Caption: so so how can we make function
Caption: programming attractive to you or how can
Caption: we can you communicate why it's
Caption: interesting right so of course there's
Caption: also the other half of the curve about
Caption: but I'm not interesting that tonight
Caption: because this is a problem for another
Caption: day so one reason why I am saying all
Caption: this is something Amy already mentioned
Caption: we've got lambda cap
Caption: sorry it's in Sydney I know it's far
Caption: away I just noticed it's far away I
Caption: spent five hours on a plane
Caption: but it's a really fun conference now so
Caption: forth until now the idea with lambda
Caption: tram has always been to be a conference
Caption: basically for the early adopters all the
Caption: talks are kind of what we call
Caption: intermediate to advanced level the idea
Caption: is people who have maybe spent the
Caption: weekends kind of trying to learn a
Caption: functional programming language now at
Caption: the point where they understand the
Caption: basics but they want to get to the next
Caption: level in order to introduce it to their
Caption: team that was the purpose of the
Caption: conference that was always this design
Caption: if you're one of these people you still
Caption: got another five days to submit
Caption: something please do everybody who erased
Caption: their hand really are going to ask about
Caption: functional programming but as Amy also
Caption: already explained there's something new
Caption: we are doing this for the first time the
Caption: welcome to FP day so this is a day of
Caption: workshops a few workshops where the idea
Caption: is to take it bit slow take our time to
Caption: introduce people who who haven't taught
Caption: it that much know or not that much
Caption: experience this functional programming
Caption: and but I interested and get them show
Caption: them the basics basically a so you can
Caption: use function programming if you like to
Caption: and at least you know what people talk
Caption: about and you can talk as well and also
Caption: of course in order to get you to a point
Caption: where you can throw the other two days
Caption: of the conference that's why the Welcome
Caption: Day is the day before the two main
Caption: conference days right and yeah I'm going
Caption: to give an introduction to functional
Caption: programming and what I want to do today
Caption: is tell you a little bit about the idea
Caption: behind it so the question is how what's
Caption: wrong with the way function programming
Caption: has been presented so far and why and
Caption: and how can we change it right so so why
Caption: why am I here well the reason I'm here
Caption: is because together with Gabriele Aquila
Caption: we at the University of New South Wales
Caption: we've been teaching functional
Caption: programming and Haskell to literally
Caption: thousands of people that's from first
Caption: year students up to postgraduate
Caption: students people who are experienced
Caption: developers and to master's degree or
Caption: postgraduate degree so while doing that
Caption: we've put quite a lot of energy in
Caption: figuring out how can we teach from the
Caption: programming properly we've done a lot of
Caption: surveys to get feedback on what works
Caption: what doesn't work what's the right
Caption: approach and so on so we've distilled a
Caption: lot of what we learned into this thing
Caption: which is an online a free online
Caption: tutorial on Hezbollah so if you want to
Caption: learn Hezbollah and you don't want to
Caption: wait until the welcome to FPA
Caption: for length of time or for Tony to issue
Caption: in a few weeks
Caption: well you can hop online and just get
Caption: going and so this is it's a tutorial
Caption: it's you don't have to have any previous
Caption: knowledge of function programming it
Caption: includes screencasts of life programming
Caption: so you can see what happens and and so
Caption: on so that's the background that's where
Caption: I am coming from basically so I'm not
Caption: working at unist up here anymore but I
Caption: did that for quite a while
Caption: so let's return to our earlier story
Caption: about this innovators early adopters
Caption: early majority so I think one reason why
Caption: functional programming is kind of
Caption: mysterious is because the communication
Caption: a lot of the communication has been
Caption: between these groups the innovators and
Caption: the early adopters and they tend to
Caption: speak in their own language and if you
Caption: just hop in the middle of it and you
Caption: listen it just makes no sense whatsoever
Caption: so why is that so there are few reasons
Caption: so one reason which X is quite similar
Caption: if you look at how programming
Caption: programming languages are taught very
Caption: often it's done in a very like language
Caption: construct for language construct kind of
Caption: way it's like today we are going to do
Caption: while loops and next week we are going
Caption: to do class definitions but that's wrong
Caption: it kind of guided at the language what
Caption: you really want to teach is the concepts
Caption: it's like if you draw if you're supposed
Caption: to learn to drive and today we are going
Caption: to do the steering wheel and tomorrow
Caption: we're going to do brakes what do you
Caption: want to practice driving come on right
Caption: so the individual bits they don't tell
Caption: you that much and especially going by
Caption: programming language constructs not very
Caption: helpful so there's a nice paper by Phil
Caption: Eisen findly flat and Krishnamurti who
Caption: we were talking who did a lot of work at
Caption: a few universities in the u.s. Rice
Caption: University no North North Eastern
Caption: opportunity teaching program teaching
Caption: programming languages and
Caption: and they make this point quite clearly
Caption: if you're interested in teaching and
Caption: learning programs interesting paper to
Caption: read so that's number one number two a
Caption: grave mistake which innovators like to
Caption: do over and over again is look at the
Caption: innovator that person has been there
Caption: when the language was invented they
Caption: solved all the problem to make 50
Caption: mistakes until they got to the right
Caption: solution now when they tell you about it
Caption: they're very keen to tell you the whole
Caption: story for them it's the whole thing
Caption: right but you don't care you want to
Caption: know what's the goal of the journey all
Caption: right you don't want to know
Caption: the historic way of getting there so in
Caption: in the Haskell community as an example
Caption: this is thing do you know category three
Caption: who knows category theory it's a rather
Caption: abstract branch of mathematics so I'm
Caption: not surprised that you don't know about
Caption: it but there's an Italian mathematician
Caption: see slash theoretical computer scientist
Caption: his name's Eugene yomogi he's very smart
Caption: person he understands category theory in
Caption: contrast to me and he figured out a way
Caption: to use that abstract mathematical those
Caption: concepts to still quite mathematical
Caption: kind of formalize the semantics of all
Caption: kinds of programming languages not just
Caption: fun to program imperative programming
Caption: object-oriented program and so on was
Caption: really breakthrough really significant
Caption: work in the area of semantics of
Caption: programming languages and then there was
Caption: another second very smart scientist
Caption: brilliant scientist Phil Wadler some of
Caption: you may have heard of him he took those
Caption: ideas from mokey and he forgot Wow
Caption: you can't just mortal the semantics of
Caption: programming languages you can use these
Caption: ideas to structure functional programs
Caption: and since then people have figured out
Caption: how to structure C++
Caption: and I mean it's not actually constrained
Caption: 200 programming how to a very clear
Caption: principle for structuring programs
Caption: software and you may have heard these
Caption: kind of thing
Caption: monads one of the scary words in FP land
Caption: right so when people are asked can you
Caption: explain mana to me
Caption: then thereof well Monat is a term
Caption: from category theory at that point
Caption: everybody runs away because who knows
Caption: category theory we had one person in the
Caption: room okay and that's this kind of half
Caption: joke half truth in Haskell and it's kind
Caption: of to kind of put make that point is
Caption: well a mana is just mono it in the
Caption: category of in the funk test what else
Caption: do you need to know it's not very
Caption: helpful right but the problem is exactly
Caption: these explaining things in historical
Caption: well well the concept of a mana in front
Caption: of programming originates over a few
Caption: steps from category theory
Caption: so people who know about this they come
Caption: oh well we have to stand at the
Caption: beginning but really most people don't
Caption: know want to know about that they just
Caption: want to know how can i structure my
Caption: program so you have to explain things in
Caption: terms which are accessible to the
Caption: student right which stand on their own
Caption: without the historical explanation let's
Caption: I think one of the biggest obstacles we
Caption: are one of the biggest problems which
Caption: makes a lot of the existing writing on
Caption: function programming inaccessible
Caption: because it takes this historical
Caption: approach all right so that's the
Caption: innovators
Caption: how about the early adopters so early
Caption: adopters I mean they're further removed
Caption: from the innovation but they still
Caption: because they're happy to invest quite a
Caption: lot to learn something new they're happy
Caption: to go to these abstract levels to read
Caption: about maybe we category theory something
Caption: like that and and understand things
Caption: things from there but that doesn't work
Caption: in general so they have a hard time
Caption: communicating very often to for example
Caption: their team why why is it useful how does
Caption: it work because the explanations has
Caption: comes comes from the abstract instead of
Caption: from the concrete what you really have
Caption: to do is you have to lead with examples
Caption: so for example coming into the room
Caption: saying well today I'm going to explain
Caption: to you what parametric polymorphism is
Caption: it's not very helpful because you have
Caption: no idea what parametric polymorphism is
Caption: so why would you even care it's the
Caption: wrong starting point what you have to do
Caption: you have to start explaining why by way
Caption: of some examples so for example you
Caption: could have in your favorite programming
Caption: language a few different examples of
Caption: functions computing the length of list
Caption: for the list of different element types
Caption: and go like look at that code looks
Caption: pretty similar right why do I have to
Caption: retype that so that gets you to a
Caption: problem statement you go like how do you
Caption: reuse that code can't be kind of write
Caption: less code because seems like it's all
Caption: doing the same thing that seems super
Caption: superfluous now from there you can
Caption: introduce a generic function and then
Caption: you do that a few more times and then
Caption: you can come to the plural concept
Caption: parametric polymorphism or sometimes
Caption: mistake link called generics
Caption: generics trust to general cleaner ex
Caption: means everything it has too many
Caption: meanings I mean anyway that's not my
Caption: point my point is we need to go from the
Caption: concrete to the abstract not the other
Caption: way around so in particular that answers
Caption: the question like do you have to be a
Caption: math superhero a math Wiz to understand
Caption: function programming no function
Caption: math can't be the starting point in the
Caption: same way as category theory can't be the
Caption: starting point for structuring programs
Caption: but I think when everything is said and
Caption: done maybe in 10 years we can settle
Caption: this question I think the biggest
Caption: contribution of control programming to
Caption: programming will have been that it has
Caption: brought math and software development
Caption: further together but for that it can't
Caption: be the case we can't require everybody
Caption: to be a mathematician and then start to
Caption: apply this to software engineering
Caption: that's that makes no sense whatsoever if
Caption: what I am saying is correct then through
Caption: development software development program
Caption: development we have to see structures
Caption: which then we can live to a level where
Caption: we can talk about them in a more
Caption: abstract way and that's actually good
Caption: evidence for that who knows about this
Caption: bootstrap program and I don't mean the
Caption: web framework so this is a program which
Caption: actually came out of these courses of
Caption: these people I mentioned earlier filets
Caption: net hour who wrote this paper business
Caption: paper about teaching and from the course
Caption: they because design they developed a few
Caption: universities got together and they said
Caption: well if this is if this holds water
Caption: cleanly then shouldn't it be possible to
Caption: get kids
Caption: interested in writing exciting software
Caption: and teach the math that way and so what
Caption: they did they develop this curriculum
Caption: for children between grade six to grade
Caption: 12 and they win especially to schools in
Caption: lower social economic regions where
Caption: usually stem teaching is quite difficult
Caption: and and they taught them cutting and
Caption: fronting language called racket and they
Caption: they did all kinds of things but they
Caption: kind of did a very principled approach
Caption: driving through to its algebraic
Caption: principles and lo and behold not only
Caption: did those kids learn coding the algebras
Caption: course suddenly wind up in quite a few
Caption: schools by now
Caption: this quite a big program you can read up
Caption: about it on that web page and so they
Caption: get a lot of evidence that this actually
Caption: works it works at the at the middle and
Caption: high school level okay so why it
Caption: shouldn't work fast
Caption: all right but then there's always this
Caption: question what about all these fancy
Caption: words I said to already like parametric
Caption: polymorphism come on can't you call it
Caption: generics like everybody else
Caption: so this terminology I think is not just
Caption: it's here to stay why well let me give
Caption: you example do you know what's common to
Caption: all these words terms
Caption: somebody knows yeah they've been
Caption: proposed as alternatives for a Monat now
Caption: now that I've told you those other words
Caption: do you have a better understanding of
Caption: what amenities
Caption: so really the name wasn't the problem
Caption: was it and that's actually I think it's
Caption: wrong to try to reinvent all the names
Caption: change all the terminology why okay we
Caption: have to learn these new words and some
Caption: of them may be bit weird but first of
Caption: all that's the case for any programming
Caption: language right do you know what a
Caption: protect I have to read it off because I
Caption: can never remember it what a protected
Caption: abstract virtual based pure virtual
Caption: private destructor is and if not do you
Caption: program C++ and you don't know come on
Caption: so every I mean every technically domain
Caption: has its terminology that's just normal
Caption: and when you learn that domain you learn
Caption: the terminology goes hand-in-hand and if
Caption: it's has changed all the terminology
Caption: around we to people who learn this stuff
Caption: really a disservice why because the
Caption: learner should be able to credit to
Caption: become an expert right and if you use
Caption: different terminology then at the end of
Caption: the day you may know everything but you
Caption: don't know how to talk to somebody else
Caption: who's already being expert to you don't
Caption: know how to read a research paper or any
Caption: of the more advanced material because it
Caption: uses all different terminology that
Caption: makes no sense so I think let's just
Caption: learn that Hammond initially on the way
Caption: by learning the concepts because the
Caption: terminology is not the problem
Caption: all right so I said a lot of things
Caption: about what we shouldn't do or how we
Caption: shouldn't present functional programming
Caption: general program development so let's I
Caption: also want to make four positive points
Caption: okay four things so we already talked
Caption: about the examples but I want to
Caption: demonstrate how we can use examples to
Caption: teach abstract concepts and it's really
Caption: important to give guidance especially in
Caption: functional programming so the one of the
Caption: killer features of functional
Caption: programming is that very easy to build
Caption: abstractions but that also means it it
Caption: can be a bit intimidating in the
Caption: beginning to know how to do this and you
Caption: need some unique kind of patterns of how
Caption: to do that you can't just do it freeform
Caption: in the beginning and then we can with
Caption: development tools we can help by having
Caption: tight feedback loops and we can use
Caption: visualizations especially in functional
Caption: programming when you don't have side
Caption: effects visualizations convey really
Caption: good intuition so I want to show you
Caption: examples of that so let's start with the
Caption: examples typically when you teach
Caption: functional programming the first concept
Caption: which causes trouble is recursion that's
Caption: the case for people who haven't
Caption: programmed before but it's also the case
Caption: for people like you who are experienced
Caption: developers in fact so in our experience
Caption: when you've been teaching functional
Caption: programming to first-year students the
Caption: students without programming experience
Caption: they usually didn't have a hard time
Caption: understanding haskell is the people who
Caption: already did little basic who had a
Caption: problem that's interesting but i'm
Caption: discretion so let's look at recursion
Caption: a typical kind of way wrong way of
Caption: explaining recursion kind of doing the
Caption: well let's start with the masse kind of
Caption: bit is the following because it will
Caption: it's super powerful but also really
Caption: simple this definition in comprehensible
Caption: Haskell code is helpless the everything
Caption: about recursion that is to say at least
Caption: wrong mathematical point of view it's so
Caption: simple is it looks awesome
Caption: it's also totally confusing and useless
Caption: all at once it doesn't tell us how
Caption: recursion works it can doesn't tell us
Caption: how we can use it how we can solve a
Caption: problem and why we would even bother in
Caption: the first place so what's a better way
Caption: let's take a simple example let's
Caption: suppose we want to write a function not
Caption: sum which adds all the numbers from n
Caption: down to zero in Haskell super easy
Caption: because we can just write this this is a
Caption: valid Haskell program well not the dot
Caption: dots but you can just write more lines
Caption: okay I leave it to your imagination the
Caption: interface for every number what you have
Caption: to add up but we can we can build on
Caption: that okay we can notice that actually
Caption: for every line the liner path is
Caption: included in line below so we can reuse
Caption: the liner path okay that's more compact
Caption: so then the next thing we notice all the
Caption: lines except the first one they're
Caption: basically the same except for the number
Caption: I mean you experienced developers so if
Caption: something is the same except for one
Caption: thing which varies in the same way we
Caption: use
Caption: variable right and then we are left with
Caption: two equations and that in fact is the
Caption: recursive Haskell program to do the
Caption: computation we set out to do so this is
Caption: constructive way to actually get to that
Caption: recursive program now I know this is a
Caption: super simple example but I on purpose I
Caption: want to make it super simple because I
Caption: don't want to this track from the point
Caption: with the complexity of the example right
Caption: this is how you can write recursive
Caption: functions in Haskell also more
Caption: complicated recursive function in high
Caption: school and even more if we want to know
Caption: how this definition works we can just
Caption: write it out we take and concrete
Caption: argument and then we substitute
Caption: left-hand sides for right-hand sides and
Caption: we do that until we can't do it anymore
Caption: which is when we have to hit the base
Caption: case and then we can add it all up and
Caption: this is not just kind of like this is
Caption: really it written out on paper this is
Caption: exactly the semantics of that Haskell
Caption: program this is exactly what your
Caption: computer does when it runs it this is
Caption: the semantics of the program
Caption: so so this illustrates a concept it
Caption: illustrates the concept of recursion and
Caption: it gives us an idea for how we how we
Caption: can get to a recursive definition in the
Caption: first place and yes
Caption: super simple example but this doesn't
Caption: just work for recursion it works for
Caption: more complicated forms of recursion it
Caption: also works for high order functions
Caption: parametric polymorphism type classes
Caption: even for categorical structures stuff
Caption: like monads so this approach scales to
Caption: all kinds of abstractions it's basically
Caption: a way of introducing abstractions in a
Caption: constructive manner in a manner where
Caption: you see what happens as opposed by
Caption: giving you definition and letting you
Caption: figure out the rest by itself all right
Caption: that's example so how about this design
Caption: patterns when I say design patterns I
Caption: don't mean exactly what you would
Caption: recognize as design patterns in
Caption: object-oriented programming although
Caption: there are some similarity what I mean is
Caption: that for example with recursion let's
Caption: stick with recursion there recursion is
Caption: on one hand so simple and the other hand
Caption: subchannel they're given a problem there
Caption: are so many ways in which you could
Caption: write a recursive function that when
Caption: you're not used to it it's you don't
Caption: even know where to start and in fact
Caption: even if I mean for you people who are
Caption: all experienced developers recursion has
Caption: still still an obstacle because in other
Caption: programming languages you may be use
Caption: recursion when you traverse a tree or
Caption: something once in a while but usually
Caption: try to use a loop or some other way but
Caption: in Haskell for example in most
Caption: functional programming a recurrence like
Caption: the Hema use for almost everything right
Caption: so the recursive definitions are quite a
Caption: bit more sophisticated so it's important
Caption: to give some guidelines like what are
Caption: the different types
Caption: recursion because they're actually not
Caption: that many so how can we get at that well
Caption: we can have one recursive function so
Caption: these functions again a haskell function
Caption: takes a list and it applies X times X to
Caption: every list element X so it squares all
Caption: elements in the list now we can have a
Caption: second recursive function looks quite
Caption: similar but it applies this to upper
Caption: function which takes a character and
Caption: turns it in uppercase character to every
Caption: element in the list now if you look at
Caption: these two definitions they are actually
Caption: except for the identifier the names
Caption: they're basically same so we can make a
Caption: more general like a pattern where
Caption: whenever we want to do something for
Caption: every element in a list or other data
Caption: structure we can just use this type of
Caption: function and trust very about writing
Caption: the orange bit and not everything else
Caption: that's important because if you have a
Caption: programming problem and you you know you
Caption: have this empty screen on your editor
Caption: and the cursors can't be this is the
Caption: worst bit right how to get started if
Caption: you already know you can use this
Caption: pattern you only have to fill in the
Caption: orange bit that's much more reassuring
Caption: at least there's some code and again you
Caption: may say well this is just a experience
Caption: function programmer now goes like this
Caption: is just the map function what are you
Caption: talking about yeah it's just the map
Caption: function but map function is more
Caption: complicated requires higher-order
Caption: functions and so on so before you even
Caption: get there it's important to give people
Caption: these structures and not just for map of
Caption: course there are all kinds of recursive
Caption: idioms and it's important to present
Caption: them or categorize them and say in these
Caption: different situations use this type of
Caption: recursion this type of recursion this
Caption: type of recursion and you cover 95% of
Caption: oil recursive programming problems this
Caption: way it's much easier to get started
Caption: okay so not just this is what you can do
Caption: but how do you get there alright so that
Caption: was the first two what about this tight
Caption: feedback loop so now one invention of
Caption: functional programming right from the
Caption: beginning with this was rattles with
Caption: eval print loop you you have like a
Caption: command trial where you can type
Caption: expressions of your programming language
Caption: and it gives you answers now we can do
Caption: even better and we can give continuous
Caption: feedback while you write your program
Caption: and that's super helpful so this is just
Caption: part of a screencast from this tutorial
Caption: online tutorial which I mentioned
Caption: earlier so it's same example okay but
Caption: the important thing is is not the
Caption: definition which you know by now I mean
Caption: you're experts at recursion Haskell by
Caption: now I hope but that we can run it right
Caption: away so there's just going to be one
Caption: more case but not only that we can run
Caption: it right away
Caption: so we call nuts um on these different
Caption: arguments and that works just fine
Caption: because we covered those cases but 50
Caption: doesn't quite work because we haven't
Caption: gotten case for 50 all right good so now
Caption: we notice what I said before that we can
Caption: reuse the definition of the line above
Caption: so we can just rewrite these equations
Caption: and then we would expect I mean if I'm
Caption: right and this right way to go about
Caption: writing these functions then the result
Caption: students Ames I mean it's not a proof
Caption: this is like a super simple test case
Caption: but gives you immediate feedback you're
Caption: on the right path okay the
Caption: transformations you're doing to your
Caption: program actually go in the right way and
Caption: then when we notice that we can actually
Caption: introduce a variable get rid of all
Caption: these superfluous equations then again
Caption: we see that the results they the same
Caption: but not only that
Caption: the core 250 between work before work
Caption: sunny so obviously this is the general
Caption: definition so the important thing here
Caption: is that you're there's no you write code
Caption: for half an hour and maybe get syntax
Caption: mistakes for another half hour and then
Caption: you compile stuff and then you run stuff
Caption: but you get feedback right away now this
Caption: is not particular to functional
Caption: programming you can in principle do this
Caption: with any programming language but
Caption: something which is quite in the in the
Caption: list in the tradition of functional
Caption: programming and I think we can Cooper
Caption: supercharge this in this way playgrounds
Caption: like this ok so this is what I mean by
Caption: tight feedback loops so we can use tools
Caption: to make it easier to learn this stuff
Caption: and one special thing about function
Caption: programming is the equations everything
Caption: is sound so equals on so and you can
Caption: replace one thing being equal by another
Caption: thing being equal and you'll never break
Caption: your program in contrast to see Java and
Caption: every programming language which allows
Caption: you to have side effects in the middle
Caption: of things so this approach works even
Caption: with big programs okay so that's type
Caption: feedback loop so how about the
Caption: visualization again recursion or today's
Caption: recursion day so there's this AI concept
Caption: of fractal trees which really
Caption: beautifully represents recursion
Caption: visually and as I said before for pure
Caption: functional data structures this works in
Caption: a general way a very general way you can
Caption: visualize them very well because again
Caption: there are no side effects in the
Caption: construction there's no destructive
Caption: people so the idea here is we start with
Caption: a square and the top thing is the base
Caption: and then we draw a triangle on top and
Caption: the two sides of the triangle that's
Caption: where you put the next square and
Caption: another one and another one and another
Caption: one and another one you get a pre like
Caption: thing all right
Caption: so we
Caption: can do this in code now here I come over
Caption: here because she's in the other screen
Caption: so here we see practically forget all
Caption: the other stuff the recursion looks like
Caption: a start to recursive function but it's
Caption: not recursive just one list element
Caption: hence we only have this one thing over
Caption: there okay so that's good so now we go
Caption: and we add a recursive call to the
Caption: fractal tree function and as we do that
Caption: we see that the tree grows right but we
Caption: have only one recursive call so it's
Caption: linear as the recursion depth increases
Caption: so what we can do we can just take this
Caption: recursive call and copy it so we get two
Caption: recursive calls but we use that second
Caption: color for the second roof of the
Caption: triangle and lo and behold we get a tree
Caption: okay so then when we increase the
Caption: recursion depth the tree grows so this
Caption: gives this is really the recursion of
Caption: that function visualized right and
Caption: actually these trees you can if you play
Caption: with the parameters you can do some
Caption: really nice graphics so it's also fun
Caption: and it gives a visual understanding and
Caption: intuition of how the computational
Caption: structure works and you can do that for
Caption: a lot of things in functional program
Caption: it's a really good way to build
Caption: intuition so that's the other tool which
Caption: i think is really useful so much better
Caption: than starting with math start with some
Caption: graphics and then do the math later if
Caption: you like
Caption: so one contentious issue which you may
Caption: I'm sure this is like you take a group
Caption: of developers and then you ask this
Caption: question should we use strict type
Caption: systems yes or no fight
Caption: you'll have fun with that every single
Caption: time so you may wonder I mean from the
Caption: program makes a lot of fuss about type
Caption: systems right but then their languages
Caption: like Lisp like the first function
Caption: programming language who didn't have a
Caption: type system so should we use type system
Caption: should we use type systems maybe you
Caption: should ask why why does anybody use a
Caption: type system you must have an opinion
Caption: I'm sure compile time safety so any
Caption: other opinions it's good one of course
Caption: proving your program semantics that's
Caption: hard call to get in your way are
Caption: dissenting opinions you define states
Caption: that make sense yeah so you you went
Caption: further but otherwise it's kind of like
Caption: getting this direction right like the
Caption: type system is kind of it's there to
Caption: don't do this it's going to crash your
Caption: program bad programmer but think about
Caption: it an architect right not today you
Caption: today an architect you see the program
Caption: everything no no like 20 years back once
Caption: draw a diagram they've got a ruler now
Caption: this ruler is this like
Caption: constraining the person I can only draw
Caption: straight lines with this thing now
Caption: it's a design tool and the same for type
Caption: system you shouldn't view a type system
Caption: of something which doesn't let you do
Caption: certain things if you use it like you
Caption: can use it like this and yeah you
Caption: you get compile time safety and you
Caption: constrain your States but type systems
Caption: are much more beautiful they can help
Caption: you to write your program instead of
Caption: just checking that your program does
Caption: certain things or doesn't do certain
Caption: things in fact so let me get back to
Caption: Phil Eisen and and and Finland sand
Caption: flats and Krishnamurthy this work which
Caption: was this origin paper and remember the
Caption: bootstrap program which they did at high
Caption: schools and middle schools that came
Caption: with the paper was actually explanation
Caption: of the approach they took in this Prague
Caption: called how to design programs and I
Caption: mentioned before they used record or
Caption: they're still using record for this and
Caption: record is a variant of scheme which is a
Caption: list like language so it's it doesn't
Caption: have static type discipline nevertheless
Caption: in this program which is about this in
Caption: this book which is about designing
Caption: programs they start by saying well you
Caption: write out examples well I mean I said
Caption: that a few times today so we are on the
Caption: same same page and then they say you
Caption: write out a type signature but the
Caption: racket so you have to write the type
Caption: system signature in comment and then you
Caption: at some point you write your code and I
Caption: mean the type signatures sits there and
Caption: you can try to correlate it to person to
Caption: program but that's it
Caption: so why did they do it I mean I have to
Caption: say they also worked on contracts and
Caption: stuff to make try to get some checking
Caption: out of that but they did it because it's
Caption: a good way to write your code they wrote
Caption: the signature before they wrote the code
Caption: because writing down the signature is a
Caption: good way of getting towards writing your
Caption: program it's a good way of designing a
Caption: program even if there isn't a compiler
Caption: to protect the signature so now how much
Caption: better in a language which does check it
Caption: you get even more benefits so if you're
Caption: interested in this there's actually talk
Caption: which I gave y'all connected two years
Caption: ago and it's not about Haskell it's all
Caption: about Swift and about Swift you may know
Caption: is Apple's new language which is a
Caption: hybrid object-oriented function language
Caption: it has a very powerful type system and
Caption: you can use the Swift type system
Caption: beautifully to help you with your
Caption: program design and so that gives you if
Caption: you want to know more about how to do
Caption: this the UL has not only slides but also
Caption: the videos from the conference so you
Caption: can have a look so then people go but
Caption: okay maybe I can somehow easy to design
Caption: my program but then I do experimentation
Caption: prototyping then that I want to run my
Caption: program but then I get a type error and
Caption: the compiler annoys me and I have to fix
Caption: this first and otherwise I can don't
Caption: can't do tests or when I respect that
Caption: then it takes ages to compile it again
Caption: well truth be told this is a problem
Caption: with your tools it's a problem with your
Caption: compiler let's look at Haskell
Caption: so you'll see has something we call
Caption: default the third type error message so
Caption: here we have a program the top thing
Caption: data is a definition of a data type of
Caption: expression Crees can be addition
Caption: multiplication or integer literals in
Caption: the opposite order and then we have an
Caption: evil function which for each of these
Caption: cases tells you how to evaluate it and
Caption: on the on the right hand side are three
Caption: different examples of doing the
Caption: evaluation with first only internet in
Caption: petrol literal than additions and
Caption: everything now what if we want to add
Caption: equality at the moment the eval function
Caption: returns an int but if equality it has to
Caption: return a bool to
Caption: we have to change the type of the
Caption: function so we introduce a new type
Caption: value which returns either an int or a
Caption: bool right where you can be in or pool
Caption: one of the two and you can read the
Caption: vertical bar as all its into a boil but
Caption: now I have to change the type of eval
Caption: and look what happens we get a type
Caption: error so but I'm not fast I'm just going
Caption: to to fix the first case the case of
Caption: Trustee in title literal by returning a
Caption: trustee in but the interval of Ind and
Caption: now if you look at the at the right hand
Caption: side on the playground look the first
Caption: example runs let's the example which
Caption: only uses an integer value but there is
Caption: still a type error of course because the
Caption: second case I mean still wrong and if
Caption: you look at the exception on the right
Caption: hand side well it's just the type error
Caption: but SLE exception so what's the idea
Caption: here the ideas are simple if your
Caption: program has a type error then that means
Caption: that part of the program we had the type
Caption: error is you can't run but that's true
Caption: in Python 2 you just get any exception
Caption: when you actually get there what why
Caption: should you be able to run the rest of
Caption: the program except maybe your compilers
Caption: too stupid to generate the code but
Caption: that's compiler construction issue not a
Caption: fundamental type system issue so how
Caption: about we fix this next example so
Caption: we add the case expression to pattern
Caption: match on the two impulse which we should
Caption: get if you want to add them but maybe we
Caption: don't know what to return as a result
Caption: and then what we do which has put an
Caption: underscore what underscore means I'm
Caption: quite sure compiler can you help me and
Caption: then you click the error message and the
Caption: error message says on top
Caption: a whole there's a hole in my program but
Caption: the hole has a type
Caption: colon colon is Haskell speak for on the
Caption: right-hand side of colon colon is a type
Caption: incest value so value is the new data
Caption: type we introduced and this new data
Caption: type introduced value has only two cases
Caption: can be indoor pool now I'm implementing
Caption: the addition case which one has does it
Caption: have to be in there's no choice really
Caption: this program writes itself so we put the
Caption: in case in well but then I'm still not
Caption: quite sure how to continue so I put a
Caption: hole again and now if I look at the
Caption: error message then it says well the
Caption: thing should be of type int the argument
Caption: I give to impel and lo and behold
Caption: there's also a list of all the variables
Caption: in scope and there are only two
Caption: variables v1 and v2 which are off type
Caption: int that's the only stuff I can put in
Caption: there right and I want to do a addition
Caption: so I probably want to add the two and
Caption: well let's try that so I add these two
Caption: variables v1 and v2 and yeah one more
Caption: trace done and then we just do the same
Caption: thing for for the last case so look at
Caption: that with those holes we didn't have a
Caption: choice right I mean once the compiler
Caption: told us what type we had to put there
Caption: there was very little choice and it was
Caption: quite clear from the context what we had
Caption: to do so type error message this can
Caption: write help you write your program and
Caption: the stronger your type system the more
Caption: information the better the compiler can
Caption: help you okay that's what I mean by
Caption: types use it to design your program not
Caption: just to complain about the compiler
Caption: giving you a hard time all right
Caption: so this is already about tools right
Caption: every compiler for a language is
Caption: types which allow you to run the program
Caption: even when it has type errors not for
Caption: production code but as an option for
Caption: debugging testing refactoring that
Caption: during the refactoring you can test the
Caption: things which you've rather have affected
Caption: even if some are still typing correct
Caption: should be able to run the rest right so
Caption: now I'm going to make a statement which
Caption: is going to make some people unhappy I
Caption: mean the one way to get everybody to
Caption: fight in the room is to ask do you want
Caption: to type system or not the other other
Caption: thing you could do is like what's your
Caption: favorite editor and we I mean I added a
Caption: modern one as well but a lot of the
Caption: stuff you're using is quite old all
Caption: right
Caption: remember beginning of this talk I talked
Caption: about structured program object on that
Caption: program now we do function programming
Caption: so a lot happened in programming
Caption: languages over those years do you want
Caption: to tell me that all we can do in tools
Caption: it's the same stuff we did 30 years ago
Caption: I mean it's not very plausible that this
Caption: is the end of the road
Caption: we've reached the optimum we can't
Caption: improve anymore really do you know this
Caption: guy this website and who's behind it the
Caption: this website is of a chap who's name is
Caption: Brett Victor he was at Apple and
Caption: wherever I mean he was in all kinds of
Caption: places now said Y Combinator research
Caption: and he the have a look at the website at
Caption: those talks he has nice ideas I mean
Caption: here's this concept of how programming
Caption: environments could work and very
Caption: interesting ideas and some people have
Caption: started to try to put them into practice
Caption: so for example two other people from Y
Caption: Combinator research they have this
Caption: experimental programming system which
Caption: which doesn't just let you evaluate
Caption: things while they're running but gives
Caption: you other information about intermediate
Caption: values and call trees and so on and it's
Caption: all when you change your program the
Caption: stuff
Caption: changes right away right it's not like a
Caption: profiler you do it and then we wait half
Caption: an hour immediate feedback type feedback
Caption: loops or you've seen like the app I used
Caption: for the Haskell programs has to format
Caption: has this idea of playgrounds which
Caption: evaluate all the time you see what's
Caption: happening immediately and it's not just
Caption: Haskell for Mac we I mean which we are
Caption: using for example you for teaching and
Caption: it's as a teacher it's great and Hurston
Caption: for Mac users liked liked it as well but
Caption: Apple has this idea of playgrounds as
Caption: well so for Swift Xcode has Swift
Caption: playgrounds and then apples introduced
Caption: this with playgrounds app for iPad in
Caption: including mechanism to write tutorials
Caption: in it and who have seen that who's tried
Caption: it few people well everybody who's kind
Caption: of can get an iPad steal it from your
Caption: kids or whatever
Caption: have a look at the app it's really nice
Caption: again it's this idea of you do something
Caption: you get immediate feedback and Apple has
Caption: put quite a lot of energy into the
Caption: situation where a lot of people are
Caption: calling for like every every kid should
Caption: learn to code right and then the parents
Caption: go to school you have to teach our kids
Caption: how to code and the teachers go like I
Caption: have no idea how to write so after has
Caption: seen this opportunity and they've
Caption: actually done a lot of teacher training
Caption: they have developed the curriculum for
Caption: Swift obviously and they're using this
Caption: app and it's quite nice so I use my kids
Caption: as guinea pigs you know so my now 13
Caption: year he was 13 years at the time not
Caption: this summer last summer I had him to all
Caption: the tutorials in switch playgrounds in
Caption: this summer I wrote an iOS iPhone app
Caption: with him so it works right so I think
Caption: there's a lot we can do with tooling
Caption: it's just like people bit lazy pushing
Caption: to leaning forward and we still use the
Caption: same
Caption: same stuff as we did a long time ago
Caption: alright so that's my point example
Caption: driven strategy you have to start put
Caption: them up don't start with the abstraction
Caption: start with the concrete work your way up
Caption: they're important to introduce design
Caption: patterns to guide people to how to use
Caption: this stuff don't just put it out there
Caption: there has to be concrete recipes for how
Caption: to use different styles of recursion
Caption: Pullum office or the stuff tight
Caption: feedback loops and visualization helps a
Caption: lot and well if you want to learn
Caption: Haskell you see there are lots of
Caption: options now you can do online tutorial
Caption: you can go to Tony's course you can come
Caption: to lambda2 mmm
Caption: it's all happening thank you very much
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: with playgrounds the teaching the
Caption: imperative program includes the
Caption: conditionals but there's not a lot of
Caption: continuity and just taking pure
Caption: functional stuff is it is there any bit
Caption: you know that's sort of focused towards
Caption: kids yeah you're totally right so with
Caption: for example switch playgrounds I said I
Caption: I'm using it but and I like the app a
Caption: lot and they've they fully thought about
Caption: how to teach the individual things but
Caption: approach I don't like very much it's
Caption: very state driven in the beginning and
Caption: well there's not so much out there I
Caption: mean the guy at the the 13 year the guy
Caption: who did switch playgrounds for 13 I we
Caption: start him on Haskell when he was nine so
Caption: it was okay I think the perfect age at
Caption: that age the kids at school they've
Caption: learned about function definitions and
Caption: they use now 2d coordinate systems
Caption: because often they want to do some gave
Caption: me kind of things so it's good to know
Caption: coordinate systems functions and you
Caption: said I mean not some is really easy kind
Caption: of pocket it's kind of like what's in
Caption: the deal and they don't overthink it in
Caption: whole you write it out on paper it does
Caption: exactly the same thing but there's very
Caption: very little material so there's one
Caption: thing this code world is kind of an
Caption: online the environment to do Haskell and
Caption: the person I forgot his name something
Caption: Smith who did code word he has used this
Caption: specifically he's developed the thing to
Caption: teach middle school
Caption: I think level just for fun I think and I
Caption: think he has some material around it but
Caption: there's not a lot out there that's
Caption: absolutely true
Caption: let's go for Mac thank ya the curriculum
Caption: really so I mean when I taught Leon so
Caption: I've got a github repository which if
Caption: you go might have account and it's
Caption: something how let Scout I think it's got
Caption: the repo and this has some even older
Caption: stuff using claws and so on but it it
Caption: has notes which I used to describe I
Caption: actually at some point I deliver safely
Caption: and I asked him to bring a few friends
Caption: so I had ten children ten to eleven
Caption: years old and I kind of tried to teach
Caption: them together and we did Haskell was fun
Caption: and yeah so there's some notes in there
Caption: on the steps I took what I started with
Caption: and so on but this is all kind of quite
Caption: scattered material I don't think there's
Caption: a really nice thing I I'm not aware of
Caption: anything which is really like a full
Caption: thing you could take and just do so more
Caption: work to be done
Caption: based on accessing a relational database
Caption: and getting rich data structures into
Caption: your program and providing the right use
Caption: case for them would you say that type of
Caption: program is fit for purpose for use in
Caption: the functional programming pattern
Caption: because I get the sense that until the
Caption: programming is very suitable for your
Caption: training crate complex calculations and
Caption: computations but to me it doesn't really
Caption: translate into that world where you
Caption: don't really necessarily need that
Caption: computation we just need to get data or
Caption: relational database yes so you can
Caption: totally use functional programming
Caption: languages for that very well in fact I
Caption: mean to certain extent sequel is
Caption: actually a functional programming
Caption: language it's a domain-specific language
Caption: but really a funky language and usually
Caption: there's quite a mismatch between sequel
Caption: and the language you use it in and in
Caption: language like Haskell you can make this
Caption: much more seamlessly you can actually
Caption: use a subset of Haskell SEO sequel
Caption: queries and even have type safety get
Caption: the type checker to help you design your
Caption: secure queries and stuff so that's
Caption: totally possible and if you look at the
Caption: Haskell libraries than their ex
Caption: different database libraries out there
Caption: so generally I mean data processing is
Caption: something you can do very well you can
Caption: do this more mathematical numerical
Caption: stuff but you just plain data processing
Caption: data science the kind of things not just
Caption: the numerical things but also just kind
Caption: of having big data sets looking for
Caption: things searching for things combining
Caption: things works beautifully in functional
Caption: languages and yeah
Caption: Madeline I'm a bit of a skeptic of the
Caption: can you put us back to business example
Caption: so in light of that thing one of the
Caption: toughest things I've found is to do
Caption: things like how variations on a GUI
Caption: where it's going to vary it's kind of a
Caption: mental problem we've got chocolate
Caption: varying depending on the nature of the
Caption: data that's there so is anybody
Caption: documented kind of like Hello plan s :
Caption: Fe you know business programming and
Caption: since it's an extension of those sort of
Caption: things with examples because most
Caption: examples I see tend to go down in the
Caption: data structures yeah so I mean one
Caption: problem which we are definitely having
Caption: is a documentation teaching problem in
Caption: that there's a there's a lot of beginner
Caption: material along those lines then there's
Caption: really high level stuff which you find
Caption: it PL conferences or something like that
Caption: and there's very little in the middle
Caption: and this is the reason why we originally
Caption: created lamda time to provide
Caption: information in the middle not in a
Caption: written form but in the form of a
Caption: conference where you can go you can
Caption: actually talk to people you get people
Caption: who actually use this stuff in
Caption: production and they can tell you their
Caption: experiences what works what doesn't work
Caption: and so on which I think at this level is
Caption: much more convincing than just having a
Caption: write-up and and slowly we are getting
Caption: more written things at the intermediate
Caption: language level as well but there's still
Caption: there's still huge gaps as you're saying
Caption: that's totally true nevertheless I mean
Caption: so I'm mostly working for software
Caption: consultancy to Akaya at the moment and
Caption: tweak is most of our project involves
Caption: function programming usually it's a mix
Caption: of things it's Heslin Java Haskell and
Caption: are other things combined
Caption: but we are see the uptake at the moment
Caption: is enormous and tweek plays a lot in
Caption: distributed systems numerical computing
Caption: data science biopharma that kind of
Caption: domain but there is also a lot of use of
Caption: functional program in especially
Caption: investment banks also in the blockchain
Caption: space is very popular in fact the
Caption: program web a project I am working on at
Caption: the moment this was ihk which is one of
Caption: the blockchain companies and yes so the
Caption: this technology is very applicable to
Caption: those domains
Caption: it's just that yeah that's not a lot of
Caption: information out there except in the
Caption: heads of people who started doing it but
Caption: that's that's at the stage where we are
Caption: at the moment it's unfortunate I totally
Caption: see it but yeah right but by now we have
Caption: I mean we there are projects lots of
Caption: projects out there now it's just at the
Caption: moment we're at the stage where you have
Caption: to know somebody you can talk to who has
Caption: got this experience but there are quite
Caption: a lot of people with that experience out
Caption: there by now so it's getting easier and
Caption: I think the conferences and so on that
Caption: helps speed easier than writing a book
Caption: it's time-consuming yeah it's hard to
Caption: say so in my opinion I think we are in
Caption: the transition from early adopters to a
Caption: limit charity which is why it's getting
Caption: interesting now this is why we I mean we
Caption: haven't thought about it like this when
Caption: you introduce the welcome to FPA it's
Caption: just more and more people asking
Caption: couldn't you do something like that
Caption: before the conference or I can come to
Caption: and from that demand we did that day but
Caption: I think the reason is because we're at
Caption: that stage
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: everybody also big THANK YOU to and also
Caption: to DDD first for being our community
Caption: partner for this evening